Oh
we talk a lot about the power of story
you know as a tool and technique for
transformation her interpersonal
persuasion you know it feel upgrade to
experience catharsis doesn't work right
like when it works it's such a powerful
thing I think stories are a kind of
cognitive technology they literally
colonize the brain they literally take
over they pattern our ability to discern
the sense impressions that they come in
they are a deciphering mechanism to
extract meaningful patterns out of our
lives and so stories are so powerful so
important is this tools meta patterning
that it plays out again and again and
again and every single variation and
variable Joseph Campbell talks about the
hero with a thousand faces it's always
the same hero because it's always
teaching us the same lesson it's always
providing a map to turn every experience
into a meaningful experience I almost
feel like the human beings are embedded
in their stories the human race who we
are is a story we are a narrative mine
is narrative consciousness is a self
reflecting awareness of pattern of
scoring so I think it's just it's it's
innate
we wouldn't be us without it it's a
powerful thing it's kartik thing it's an
important thing it's a thing worth
celebrating worth framing and worth you
know talking about distilling dissecting
exploring stories
hey guys be sure to check out the
dictionary of obscure sorrows which is
literally a compendium of words we've
never heard before used to describe
elusive feelings that we can barely ever
articulate but we will surely recognize
check it out